étranger
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
probablement
[Musique]
juste c'est une sorte d'exemple de
loisirs terrestres mais j'espère que mes pensées les
limites que vous voyez ici
même jusqu'à l'heure mondiale, je veux dire, j'ai
forcé beaucoup plus de lancers francs plus  ou
moins concernant une sorte de refuge sûr, de
sorte que la plupart des gens migrent
des zones rurales vers la liberté et
au fil du temps, dont la population et
augmente également et qui a en fait eu
beaucoup de
demande croissante de logements et qui a eu
recours aux gens  habitant en fait
certaines de ces colonies côtières
[Musique]
merci
nous avons des accidents d'incendie comme je l'ai dit, ils
parlent de ce nombre que les gens où
nous ne nous faisons pas virer maintenant où c'est fini
à 15 où parfois quand les gens quand
ils meurent  certaines personnes et elles brûlent aussi
oui
et avec le retour des inondations, nous pouvons obtenir une alarme
comme celle où, pendant la saison, annuler l'alarme à
des moments où la pluie s'est arrêtée tout simplement pas
bien puisque vous ne pouvez pas Je ne me sens pas
au centre du bloc
[Musique  ]